you
[Music]
good morning everyone so if you have
ever used a mock down before you can
probably recognize me so since about
2014 I have created and co-authored a
series of practice related to our mock
down like the our mock down itself and
then 2016 book ton 2017 block down so
I'm responsible for a lot of things down
except except the current government
shutdown so so today I'm going to
introduce a new member in the our marked
an ecosystem named page down so this is
joint work with an excellent
collaborator actually I should say the
the best collaborator I have ever met in
my life
named Roman Lucio
oh it's a French name story I don't I
don't really I can't really pronounce
that name
precisely alright so just before I get
started just a word of caution this
package is still very young so I would
treat it as experimental so don't set
your expectation too high Oh
so after this talk you may feel that oh
this is great so we can finally throw
away lay tech and the word and
unfortunately
the answer is not yet there are still
many rough energies well why why do I
work choose to work on this page dumb
package so basically this page down just
allows you to skip word or latex but it
basically creates page documents from
your web pages like HTML pages I
personally I have strong belief in HTML
like persevere sometimes as you say in
in HTML in the web I trust so basically
the reasons are like so first of all
hTML is very access accessible because
you only need a web browser right every
pretty much everyone has a browser so
the output from page tongue is an HTML
page so pretty much everyone can have
access to that without installing any
special software and it's also very easy
to embed interactive in rich media on
web pages and it's also much easier to
parse HTML pages than PDF documents for
example if you have a table on your HTML
page is technically it's very easy to
parse the data in the table so the
bottom line is that I think HTML and CSS
will eventually catch up with latex in
typesetting but it will be difficult for
later cords to catch up in other aspects
of HTML such as the interactivity so the
installation is pretty simple you can so
although I have released an initial
version of page down to cran I still
recommend strongly recommend you to test
this package from github so you just
install that from github and note that
this package Britain requires a higher
version of panic and dark version 2
which is bundled currently bundled in
the preview version of our studio and
because the output is HTML and
I would recommend you to use Google
Chrome or chromium to view or print the
HTML pages generated from this package
so that the usage is pretty simple so if
you are an our studio user you can just
create a new are markdown document with
the page down output format through the
menu file new file are marked on from
template and you can find a quite a few
page down templates in that list so for
those who do not use our studio I'm not
sure if you are aware of the name of
this conference that's totally fine you
don't have to use our studio you can use
any editor you like so the all the
example or the template documents are in
the source code of this package so you
can find them in the installation
directory of your package or on it hub
to preview the HTML output from page
down I recommend like for complicated
reasons as Henry would say that the most
reliable to preview a page down document
is through the weird our studio area
named infinite moon reader or equivalent
equivalently you can call a function to
preview it and to generate a PDF from
your HTML document you can just open
that HTML document in your web browser
in chrome and printed it to PDF there
there's also a function named Chrome
print in this package but at the moment
it doesn't really work perfectly well so
it will be improved in the future and
next I'm going to show you some of the
output existing output formats and
examples in this package so the first
one I would like to show you is paged
HTML documents so this is based on
another JavaScript library named page 30
GS
this is basically a library to implement
the w3c spec named paged media
properties for CSS basically it allows
you to typeset your HTML pages through
CSS but the problem is that no web
browsers really support that w3c spec so
Paige don't yes did that job so it
implemented that spec so that you can
view a page document in your web browser
the output the name of the output format
is page down colon colon HTML underscore
paged so we just specify that as your
output format and you like click the
neat button or use the infinite moon
reader and you will see page HTML
document in your browser this is just a
screenshot created from from the PDF
generated in Chrome so that that is what
paged HTML document looks like so if you
open the link here page down are behind
on Io you can hopefully you can see that
in your web in your web browser that
you've got a paged
HTML document so in this document you
can have things like the title page of
your book a table of content several
chapters math equations if your eyes are
really good he can probably see the
running header on the fourth page so you
can have headers page numbers footers
all kinds of elements that you could see
as you would see in a PDF document so
besides creating page documents you can
also create other applications like a
business card so on the left hand side
that that is just the full our markdown
sauce so you can see there's title
author output format business card and
then the body of your card so the output
would be something like the picture on
the right hand side so this is basically
an unsolicited business card I made for
mr. shiny also known as the president of
our studio you can also create a resume
from page down the output format is page
down colon colon
shanell underscore resumes so in the
knockdown source basically it looks like
this so you have an you can specify a
sidebar in the side part so you can then
it can have several subsections you can
have bulleted lists and in the main area
you can have an arbitrary number of
blocks so like listing your education
working experience so basically each
block is level 2 header and then inside
each block you can list the details
about your resume so that is what on the
resume produced from page down looks
like so if you click that link you can
also see a web page that looks almost
identical so by the way this is actually
a real resume although this is just an
example in the page down package this is
real so if you are looking for a PhD
student with strong computing skills and
knowledge in bio bio informatics you may
consider this person so and you can also
create posters HTML posters from page
down so currently I have included two
poster formats when it's called poster
relax the other is called poster Jacobs
so I will show you what they look like
so this is a poster relax
well actually this CSS style is borrowed
from another package named relaxed it's
not an R package for the nodejs package
I I only port it their CSS into page
down so yeah hopefully you can see the
our lovely car woman in the middle
smiling at you so that is what a relaxed
the poster looks like and then we've got
a poster Jacobs I yeah I basically I
found this style on a late hack website
so that I think this is probably very
famous in the late
community to create posters so basically
I saw that appearance and I wrote all
the CSS from scratch in one evening
after my little kids went to bed it took
me about two or three hours to read CSS
the total number of lines of CSS is only
about like a little over a hundred so
the CSS is really simple and in case you
are curious the technical behind the CSS
it's called the CSS grid so which allows
you to arrange elements on your posters
on agreed you can also write letters
with page down if you want so there is a
format named HTML underscore letter so I
as an example I wrote a letter of
recommendation for a meeting Anka who is
really cool hacker I believe in our
community
so the armitron source also looks simple
is from me a way to the hiring manager
in the school of ninja hackers
University the address is for for not
found Road in the undefined city in an
in a state so and then yes the letter
would look like this so you can open
that in your web browser and see the
real letter so actually since this is
this is just HTML the as I said there
are many advantages of using its HTML so
for example my slides are actually HTML
so I can embed whole letter in my slice
through an iframe so you can see the
letter live here the one thing that I'm
proud of this is that this is probably
the first letter in history that
contains a gift
so this shows this shows that this gif
shows Emmys talent and last give
actually is my description of Emmy
issues such as just like such a cool
hacker alright so well actually despite
of all these kinds of advances in
technology I feel a little sad that I
mean we receive so many letters and
emails every day and we are no longer
excited like 10 years ago right
10 years ago you would be excited to
receive an email and now you will be
excited to receive a real letter
so besides letters and you can also
write books with Paige town there's a
format named poktan underscore CRC which
is a format for the publisher Chapman ha
crc so just to give you a quick overview
so this is what the book would like
actually this is a real book that the
book done book reproduced with CSS in
HTML last I want to talk a journal
format so before that I want to mention
the the talk from Catherine Mullen at
use our 2014 conference where she
mentioned the history and future of the
Journal of statistical software Genesis
so that's the GSS was originally founded
by Maya Angelou so in Katherine slice
she actually presented the original
email of Angelou where you can find his
original proposal so that was in 1995
1995 that was quite early it was only a
few years after I learned how to put on
my own pants
and stopped wetting my bed at night so
in the proposal and he mentioned four
points he would like to create a journal
that is electronic electronic and freely
available and then done in in HTML and
interactive and peer-reviewed I want to
highlight two points in that proposal so
the journal should be done in HTML and I
would say that this is quite possible
now because of page 2 and page 2 GS and
then the papers should continue
interactive content and that is also
possible now because we have interactive
things like HTML widgets and shiny apps
so in fact we have my excellent
collaborator Roman has actually
recreated the style of Genesis through
HTML and instrument CSS so I would like
you to guess which one is HTML CSS and
which one they slay attack it's hard to
tell right it's just amazing as as you
say so last I want to digress a little
bit in this technical talk to talk about
something totally non-technical because
I feel it is very important so last year
I read this book by Sigmund Freud and
they actually said heavily influenced to
me civilization and its discontent
because I could relate this to many
things in my real life like PDF and it's
this content world and is discontent
typesetting and is discontent journal
publication and it is discounted there
are just so many things I was I'm not
happy with so basically the main the
main thing that we talk about in this
book was the friction between
civilization in the individual and the
friction is between is from the instinct
individuals instinctive freedom and the
civilizations demand for conformity and
repression of instinct
so basically civilization is built up
upon control beauty hygiene and order if
you look at this worse
you may also you may often think of your
journal editor control beauty hydrogen
and order and in the last paragraph of
that book Freud said so if you if you
survey the aims of culture in Denver and
it that the means that it employs you it
come to the conclusion that the whole
effort is not worth it and even
individual will be unable to tolerate
the outcome of the civilization so I'd
like to repeat maybe the whole effort of
typesetting is just not worth it it's
just not worth the trouble
last year the the quote that influenced
me most was this we become what we
behold we shape our tools and our tools
shake hands sometimes I just feel really
confused
so when you confused you can take a look
at or you can hear what little kids say
and observe what they do
so last Saturday I told my my other son
that I would come to this conference and
give a talk and because every day when I
floss or brush brush his teeth he would
watch her video so last last Saturday I
had him watch my last year's us video
conference talk and after he finished so
that was about block down after he
finished his only comment was I want to
watch bleep in case you don't know bleep
this is flippy and his garbage truck so
so yeah I thought my last year's talk
was awesome but
of course not as important as play P so
just think about some journal type
setting guidelines like sometimes you
are required to use codes and
pre-formatted keyboards variable
environment option command file package
crammed package pro long URL is it's so
many later commands are they really
important I really don't know and I
doubt so so sometimes you just as an
adults we just forget what our original
play P was so why do we write journal
papers why do you write the right books
to share knowledge right why do you read
letters which we will show our care for
our friends or family members right so
we'll mark down in CSS save us maybe
because Martha is very limited but on
the other hand I believe it's very good
to have constraints so who is causing
the trouble actually it is it humans or
technology will CSS save us probably not
so sometimes in terms of working I mean
in the biggest tragedy is probably not
that people are lazy and they don't work
that the real tragedy is that people
working extremely hard on three vehicles
so just trivial things might help in
typesetting details alright I hope
pagedown can save you some effort in
interpreting because I think HTML CSS
are just fantastic alright thank you
okay we have time for a question hands
please
who has a question for you a we have one
right here if we can get a microphone up
front please do we want to take bets on
the pass right we're going for the safe
pass right please say your name and ask
your question please
I'm Andrew one thing that I struggle
with well there we go it's really
difficult to get our CFO to read
anything unless it is in the body of an
email so my question for a page down is
with the CSS that's in it
I know when you open it in Chrome you
can download external files but an email
client you can't so could I render that
into an email rendered yeah yeah render
the HTML and then you send an email with
the HTML file as the body yes yes there
are pecked is actually the next speaker
which he has written are what's the name
of that package no I mean the the the
package to send emails this class okay
yeah it's just asking
[Laughter]
okay we do have time for one more quick
question we've got a hand over here
please raise your hand high you don't
got it all right Damon question please
one of the reasons for all optics
popular popular today's equation
mathematical typesetting worries page
down our markdown on that for type site
setting math and equations
yeah there's their support from mathjax
[Music]